what up yo
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it is thursday april 7th
2022 we are live streaming on rumble
blaze tv and youtube tap the button
would you thank you
ladies and gentlemen don't burn this
country is out in five days go to
slash book daverubin.com
buy the book you get it yet have i
promoted it enough it's time
make the move and you can also join me
on tour where every single ticket comes
with a book oh and i have something
actually huge that i have to tell you i
had announced yesterday that the dc show
on april 25th that the folks at the
miracle theater had reneged their
promise to us and we're going to
actually force either a vaccine passport
or a negative covid test they have now
reversed their reversal and there will
be no requirement whatsoever they're
taking the information off the website
if you have a ticket you are good to go
if you don't have a ticket i hope you
will purchase a ticket you can get
tickets to that show and any other show
at daverubin.com
events none of the show have passport
requirements none of the shows have mask
requirements you do not have to be
injected anything to come see me live or
anything like that okay you get it
you're good to go we're fighting the man
and we're doing it together so just to
be a hundred percent clear the dc show
is back on
same venue we fought the system and the
system
bowed to us
dave rubin.com
events and today ladies and gentlemen we
are going to be doing a reuben report
locals community
q a but i found this incredible really
really awesome i should have seen this a
million times i don't know how this sort
of just skipped me you know sometimes
something that people have seen just
skips you i found this really really
fantastic video of steve jobs obviously
apple founder steve jobs talking about
sort of the best way you can live your
life i thought that would be a great way
to set up the q a today so we're going
to be playing that in just a second
before i get to any of that i want to
talk to you about bullying max real
quick you know as inflation surpasses
highs not seen in 40 years the value of
the dollar is decreasing with every
passing day you're paying more at the
pump the grocery store for cars for
housing face it paper money is worth
less it's true friends the timing
couldn't be any better for my new
sponsor bullion max bullion max is a
direct to consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security for your
family in times of crisis and here's why
i love bullying max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metal space
offers some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website i want to
help you get started so i worked out a
special offer with them just for you you
can get bullion max's silver starter kit
at employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com
dave this kit includes five of the most
desirable silver products to invest in
including a silver american eagle and a
silver australian kangaroo this offer is
limited to just one per household so get
yours now go to bullionmax.com
dave and now back to me okay as i've
been telling you guys lately on the show
we can mock and expose and ridicule the
ridiculous people that are seemingly in
charge of this country that's one thing
we can do but the more important thing
we can do
is talk about better ideas talk about
building new things and thinking about
new ways to solve problems
and live better lives so i came across
this video of steve jobs steve jobs
obviously passed away a couple years ago
but steve jobs the original founder of
apple and a true innovator i mean just
think about the innovation that this guy
created with apple the computer first
and then the iphone and then pretty much
what has happened to apple since then
they just make one smaller then they
make it a little bigger then it's
smaller again then it's a little more
square then it's a little more rounded
then it's thinner then it's fatter
that's all they can do now because he
was the innovator
check this out the thing i would say is
when you grow up you tend to get told
that the world is the way it is and your
your life is just to live your life
inside the world try not to bash into
the walls too much
try to have a nice family life have fun
save a little money
but life
that's a very limited life life can be
much broader once you discover one
simple fact
and that is everything around you that
you call life
was made up by people that were no
smarter than you
and you can change it you can influence
it you can you can build your own things
that other people can use
and the minute that you understand that
you can poke life and actually something
will you know if you push in something
will pop out the other side that you can
you can change you can mold it
um
that's maybe the most important thing
is to shake off this uh
this uh
erroneous notion that life is is there
and you're just going to live in it
versus embrace it change it improve it
make your mark upon it
i i think that's very important and
however you learn that once you learn it
you'll want to
change life and make it better because
it's kind of messed up in a lot of ways
once you learn that you'll never be the
same again
man how good is that
what if that is true what if that guy
steve jobs probably the greatest
innovator of this generation who put the
world in our pocket
sometimes for good sometimes for not so
good kind up to you it's a tool just
like fire it convert you and it can also
keep your house warm
what if he's right
what if actually that is the truth you
know that's very much in line with
something that i personally believe
if you build it they will come if you
say truth you can expand truth if you do
good things you'll be rewarded for it i
think my life is a pretty good example
of that what if you have the power what
if you're he-man i have the power then
you can point your sword at the cat he
turns into a giant battle cat what if
all of that is kind of right that if you
poke life and you're not afraid of
things and you push against those walls
instead of just feel that those walls
are just right in front of you and
boxing you in
what if you actually can affect change
isn't that in many ways
what we're constantly talking about on
this show when i make fun of politicians
and then at the end i'll tell you well
politicians aren't the answer even the
ones that i like even ron desantis he's
not the answer he's part of the solution
in that he's an individual standing up
against the machine and fighting to free
people but what if you actually are the
answer i think that's the truth i think
we have more power over this world than
we can possibly imagine this is a very
jordan peterson notion right like this
idea that you know if you write yourself
you can write the world everyone's doing
this thing backwards these days
everyone's complaining about the world
endlessly right i'm a victim because the
world is so evil and i'll sort of
destroy the world with me but i think
it's completely the reverse
the world is pretty good sometimes and
it's pretty bad sometimes and you got a
chance
to pilfer out some joy and satisfaction
and
worth
and value while you're on your adventure
but what if you could actually affect
change and guess what that line that he
said there that the people in charge
they're no smarter than you has there
ever been a time
in your lifetime where it was more
obvious that they are that they are not
smarter than you do you think that joe
biden and kamala harris
and jen saki and nancy pelosi
and mitch mcconnell
and lindsey graham i mean the list goes
on and on of these people or even the
media people any of the people at cnn or
any of the people at the new york times
do you think any of these people are
smarter than you or better than you or
have more worth than you or even worthy
of listening to
i don't think so
i have no doubt i don't know most of you
watching this right now but i have a
pretty good feeling you're better people
than they are so stand up for yourself
and see what you can do with the world i
think that's really the answer i
honestly believe that is the freaking
answer and now to some great questions
that are sort of in line with uh some of
that from the reubenreport.locals.com
community here we go katherine
says is there a chipotle within lunch
distance of your new place if not how
are you coping is your team still
getting regular servings of guacamole
great question catherine we felt we had
to address this one up top yes
we are actually within driving distance
short driving distance of two chipotles
we've found one chipotle that seems to
be a little fresher than the other
chipotle it's actually the further one
but we're willing to wait those extra
few minutes and i'd say we get chipotle
how often we're doing a little bit less
than la we're doing maybe really
it's really only once every three weeks
or so that we're doing the chipotle
connor over here loves the chipotle
before he uh was working here he was he
was 90 chipotle he was more chipotle
than man uh we've eased him out of that
but yes i let everybody get as much
guacamole as they want sometimes if the
show's particularly good
they get double double protein double
chicken double barbacoa
double uh what else do they got over
there they got the steak okay double
carne asada uh but yes we we do a decent
amount of chipotle we've been doing some
some middle eastern stuff we did jersey
mike's
yesterday you never know what you're
going to get over here at the reuben
report thank you for the question mark
says in light of elon's investment in
twitter do you think that more
conservatives should get on the platform
it's always seemed like a place for
people to virtue signal and or spit
venom are you hopeful that constructive
conversations might start become more
normal there
no i'm actually not very hopeful of that
because i think the nature of the
internet
in terms of the open platforms is not
very conducive to same conversation
sometimes it is but everything sort of
seems to be one way or another hijacked
by the trolls and the bots and
everything else i would say look
i think that elon getting involved in
this and hopefully pushing twitter which
whether you like it or not is an
important
vehicle for communication pushing it
towards more free speech and hopefully
unbanning some of these people such as
say donald trump i think that would be
good figuring out some of the problems
related to twitter and the conversation
and and the mobs and all that stuff that
would all be good but i would say this
if you who is the question from there
who's the name i want to get the name
right i want to speak directly to the
person mark
i want to talk directly to you if you're
uh not on twitter and you've made it
this far not on twitter don't get on
twitter don't get on twitter like if you
watch this show you're getting enough of
what's going on
on twitter and you're in the locals
community which is a much healthier
atmosphere right that's just simply the
truth we have no trolls on locals that's
how it is we've worked out a really
beautiful system and built a really nice
community but if you've made it this far
you don't need to get on twitter but i
would like twitter to be cleaned up a
little bit it would be nice if it could
happen and i think there actually is a
chance because of elon musk
jeff says do you think election laws
that were changed by edict under the
auspices of accommodation for kovid
could be rescinded and returned to
status prior to covin so this is a great
question and this is a really important
question so what you're referring to
is that during covet especially in blue
states they changed all sorts of
election laws and partly this is what
trump and some of the people on the
right were fighting that you can't just
magically even because of a pandemic
change written election laws and
suddenly allow for ballot harvesting
where you could literally have someone
not an election official just drop off a
series of ballots at a box in the middle
of nowhere and then have that box moved
or that we were doing all of this voting
uh vote you know mail-in voting for the
first time and are these things being
regulated properly and all those things
and by the way you're allowed to ask
those questions and it doesn't mean that
you're a conspiracy theorist or a scary
right-winger these are legitimate
questions to ask your question is are
they going to be rescinded or or
you know turned back in essence um i
don't think so
i think the powers that be got a lot of
results that they like and if you're a
guy like gavin newsom in california
oh god no i got to put money in the
thing i mentioned gavin newsom and i
mentioned california you know as you
guys know this is the get someone out of
cali fun to move to florida although i
have started to think we should be
changing the nature of this and it
should be to actually give money to a
lefty floridian to move to new york
we'll we'll debate that
over the next few months
but look a guy like avi newsom he's
happy with the results i told you guys
when i was voting in the recall and
obviously it was near and dear to my
heart and i was campaigning with larry
elder the way they did mail and ballots
although i did
go to my polling station and if you
remember i posted a video we showed it
on youtube where my ballot got rejected
several times i had to redo it you had
to press more i think it was 11 times if
i'm not mistaken to get to larry elder's
name on the touchscreen
but i did get the mail in ballot also
because they just send mail and ballots
to everybody whether you vote in person
or not i also didn't have to show an id
which is something else altogether but
no matter which way you folded the
ballot
in california you could either see that
you voted yes or no on recall or larry
elder's name because there's only so
many ways you can fold a three pronged
ballot right and then there's two sides
to an envelope and all you'd have to do
is hold it up to the most basic light
barely an iphone camera light and that
you could see through the envelope yes
on recall and or
i voted for larry elder do you think
there's some problems related to some of
that do you think that encourages some
bad people who might be supposedly
arbiters of truth counting ballots and
being like
oh yeah about larry elder i don't like
valeria
whoops what happened there i mean these
things are all possible and the more
that you trust the system
i think the more that the system is
allowed to mess with you so i have a
feeling a lot of these things aren't
going away what i am encouraged by
though is that certain states arizona
for one for sure and here in florida and
a couple other states are securing their
elections and making it more transparent
video counting making sure people have
ids et cetera et cetera libby says any
plans on getting tulsi on i would love
to hear the two of you together you know
she's been on a couple times tulsi is a
friend of mine she's i just i just adore
her because she's she's a decent
freaking human being we don't agree on
everything politically i'm definitely
more right of her at this point although
i think she's on her way quite nicely
but i think she still considers herself
a democrat and that's just fine
she would be what i would call a sane
democrat if such a thing existed um yeah
she's welcome to come on anytime i
really want to do it in person she
hasn't been in florida lately
so you know we we talk every now and
again and we'll make that happen for
sure
cece says the format of the show seems
to have changed since you moved to
florida what prompted you to make this
change uh you know there's two things
here one is that as you guys know i
truly feel reborn since we got to
florida i mean
i physically i literally physically feel
better and lighter and that weight is
off my chest and i feel excited again
and part of the reason that i do the
money to escape cali or force a lefty
out of florida
thing is because i'm feeling because i
was in cali and always having to talk
about cali and talk about the madness
and the ridiculousness and the awful
people and the horrible elected
officials and all that stuff and i don't
have to do that here because it's all
good so when i talk about florida here
and obviously i i talk about florida a
lot here the reason i'm talking about
florida is not just because i live in
florida so it's nice to talk about the
place i live in it's because this is the
place where freedom is expanding where
freedom is strengthening and growing so
it's like i want that to be seen i want
that to be heard so
partly i think the show changed a little
bit just because of my energy and that
sort of thing but then i got to give
credit to this guy over here phoenix who
joined us phoenix was our intern
a couple started about two years ago and
i tried i actually write about this in
don't bury this country so i'm giving
you a little tease of don't burn this
country uh phoenix was our intern and he
was going to college and he decided to
go back to college and and right before
he was going back and this is about a
year and a half ago now when i was
writing this book
i said to him hey look you're doing
great work here what are you going to
college for what's the point zoom's
class and everything's pointless and
what are you doing let me give you a job
you'll make money you'll get health
insurance you know
let's just do this and he thought about
it for a while and then he decided to go
back to school well
uh
in what roughly november or so as we
were just deciding to move to florida he
said dave i think i've had enough and uh
if that offer is still on the table i'd
like to join you and and go to florida
and move with you guys and take that job
we immediately said yes he moved he
moved here and he in the answer to the
question has really helped me figure out
the arc to the show so when we've been
doing these narrative shows where we're
pulling old clips to compare with the
new stuff and and trying to do a show
that's not just sort of oh five things
happen today here are those five things
i think we're we're doing a
more mature show i think it's i think
it's more
um it's more robust it's thick you know
i used to say to jordan when we were on
tour um when he would get off stage if
he had a particularly good show i would
say jordan that was a thick show because
it was like watching him walk through
like a thick goo he had to like walk
through it slowly and get there as
opposed to sometimes when they weren't
as great although they were always great
but obviously every now and again you're
gonna have one that isn't as good as it
was it was a little thinner tonight you
know you could just kind of walk through
the paper right there it was like a wet
paper bag you kind of walk through it
and even those were pretty damn good
really
but i think we've started to do
something that's really different here i
don't know anyone that's doing anything
like we're doing
so so credit to to phoenix right there
phoenix you can have extra guacamole
today
not for you conor all right
lynne says do you think rick grinnell
would run for president personally i
think he would be the smartest man in
the room i love rick rick is a great
friend and a good guy and a great
servant to america in the best sense of
that phrase
like rick not only was he our ambassador
to germany happened to be our first
openly gay ambassador to a g7 country
okay he's gay zippity damn duda he was
not hired because he was gay he was also
he worked under
john bolton who was the u.s ambassador
to the u.n for many years i i believe he
was his deputy so he worked at the u.n
fought all the evil snakes at the u.n
then he was
acting uh intelligence director under
trump he's got a great resume he loves
america he's still out in cali fighting
for cali so nobody's perfect i'm trying
to get him here but i think he would
make a really good president
he's a good decent guy and
i will send him this very clip
nick says for vip book tour guests does
the one second hug rule apply to doing
the arm around the shoulder pose for a
picture with you just want to make
certain to be respectful of your
boundaries wow good question appreciate
the question
i'm probably going to regret this but
the i've always felt when i've said that
you can get the one second hug that
that's separate from the picture because
you get the picture as part of the q and
a not everyone's going to want the hug
but for those of you that want the hug
you get the one second hug you don't get
the two second hug if you hold on for
more than a second you're out we've got
a cracked security team and they're
gonna take you out okay but i've i
believe that you can have the one second
hug how are you how you doing can i sign
that thing hug
picture have a nice day that's how we're
gonna do it uh kimberly says will you be
taking paternity leave when your child
is born if so who would you want to sub
in as your replacement like a guest host
for the reuben report direct message so
david and i have discussed this a little
bit
i don't think that i'm going to
partly it's because of timing at least
with
the first baby because the first baby is
due in august and you know i do the
august off the grid thing so because of
that i won't be in studio for august so
i'll be able to be around a lot and be
awake a lot and deal with the crying and
the screaming and the pooping and then
you get a kid involved it's a lot you
know what i'm saying that's an old joke
for you um
you like that one he liked that one um
so i so august that will be easy for me
for august in terms of being around
making sure we're both around world so
david's mom's going to be around his
sister is going to be around my sister
uh is giving birth i think
the the dates you know you obviously
don't always give birth on the date
you're supposed to but the day is the
day before uh our first baby is due um
and she's here in miami so like there's
going to be a lot of family and and all
that stuff around as for the second baby
which is in august i probably will have
to take a couple days off around that at
least um fortunately we're blessed with
with strong families that are going to
help us laugh who would i want to guest
host for me
you know that tucker carlson guy's not
bad but i guess he's got his own gig um
you know who i would love but we'd have
to resurrect him from the dead we'd have
to resurrect him from the dead
well of course you know of course it
could be if i could it's two dead guys
i'm gonna give you two dead guys
actually uh so the easy answer of course
is uh larry king my my friend and mentor
and and bonus grandfather if he could
just like kind of come back and do this
thing and update us on where he's at and
where he's at and whatever's going on in
the world that would be something but
there's another guy that is sort of a
more forgotten larry king in some ways
do you guys how many of you and this is
going to age some of my audience because
you young whippersnappers aren't going
to remember them tom snyder
who was a cable news host i believe he
was on cnbc for all might have been on
msnbc for a while had this crazy kind of
great comb over and he did in some ways
what was the first youtube show he used
to do a show where it was just him
directly to camera just like this but
his head was bigger so imagine if we
really zoomed in on the head and he'd
have a couple guys in the room and he
was always talking to them and kind of
laughing off camera and it was sort of
bananas i always thought the whole thing
was nuts because it was like who the
hell is he talking to does he even
realize he's on tv i always like that
tom snyder guy
cassie says i think biden or whoever is
pulling his strings cares very little
about approval ratings compared to the
great reset agenda and what they want to
accomplish on a schedule what do you
think yeah yeah and again this is like
one of those you say it and then oh my
god he's a conspiracy theorist
either this is the most inept
administration of all time and they
understand nothing that we once knew and
they don't understand basics about
economics or foreign policy or quite
literally anything that used to have
anything to do with reality or they're
intentionally destroying it and why
would you intentionally destroy it well
it sort of could be
that great reset thing connected to the
world economic forum connected to the
esg score and if you don't know what i'm
talking about watch my last interview
with uh glenn beck from about a month
and a half ago uh that they want sort of
this one world government and that will
all live in the metaverse and you'll
depending on your social credit score
you'll either be able to get a loan or
not get a loan or a bunch of other
really awful dystopian stuff
so
i suspect it's that but i'll give biden
credit where it's due does i think do i
think he's fully in on it and fully evil
no i just don't think he knows what's
going on
will says having moved from california
to florida last year in large part due
to the coveted restriction i am amazed
and a little frustrated when i see masks
being worn even in florida do you have
any thoughts as to how we can help
deprogram these people that's
interesting because i got to tell you
here in miami it's very very rare i
pretty much never
see people in masks i go to target don't
really see anyone in masks sometimes the
employees are still in masks which you
know desantis pushed for a law that was
going to stop the employee employers
from forcing the employees because he
was i saw in a press conference and i
saw a private talk he gave this idea
that when you go to a hotel you don't
have to wear a mask now but the staff
does or when you go to a big box store
you go to target you go to best buy you
go to a supermarket you go to whole
foods that the employees have to wear
but you don't it's going to create a
class war right over time it's like oh
the peons who are working they have to
wear the mask and they're somehow
diseased and less than but the average
person you don't have to or you work at
a big box store all day where you have
to wear a mask then you go out as a
consumer to the supermarket after when
you're going home from work and you can
take the mess off none of it makes any
sense but i can say generally here in
miami there's almost no masks anywhere i
wonder where in florida you are i'm
guessing probably not west coast because
i feel like they're even better about it
maybe a little more north maybe in like
a boca situation something like that
maybe a little bit
but i would say look at this point
if people so choose to wear the mask
then so be it you know some of the
people either immunocompromised
might be older they have their own
considerations they live with someone
who might be
ill or whatever it is
everyone has to make the choice for
themselves so really what i was always
concerned with was that the government
can't force you to do this and they
certainly can't kick you out of your job
or stop you
from going outside or whatever else so
at this point yeah it's when i do see it
i'm like what are you doing especially
if i see someone you know walking their
dog or something but that's very very
rare
michael says do you think that locals or
rumble will consider the use of
cryptocurrency for subscriptions or
tipping yes 100 absolutely i can't tell
you everything that's going on kind of
under the hood um but yes a hundred
percent we are you know obviously the
future of all of this is digital
currency and decentralized payments
one of the things we're trying to figure
out with locals is doing decentralized
payments
on monthly subscriptions is a little
more complex obviously because the value
of the decentralized coins of say
bitcoin or ethereum or whatever you're
using does change over time there's also
certain processing fees and whatever
that make not everything as sort of
simple as just us currency although that
is being deflated rapidly under uh this
biden fella uh but yeah we are looking
into that we've been having a couple
meetings um related to that
uh and just for the record i'm i'm
involved less in some of the
nitty-gritty more than the
the sort of big picture stuff so i talk
to them and i sort of consult on the
idea of whether we should do that sort
of thing they then kind of figure out
the nuts and bolts i'm not i'm not
running the company as much as i used to
in that regard uh cathy says who makes
you laugh the hardest when you read
their twitter feed is there anyone you
follow on twitter that we'd be surprised
to hear thank you for your levity and
wit dave wishing you every success thank
you for that kathy you know i think the
best follow on twitter i'm going to give
him a lot of credit right now is my
friend the willy wonka of politics
michael malus he is a master troll he is
a self-described troll
where you have to read his tweets
sometimes two or three times before you
fully get the joke and he's just he's
just witty and brilliant and great i
suppose that's not a surprise like who's
the surprise that i follow
well i will tell you this i used to
follow more lefty accounts and then i
just i just couldn't do it anymore
because it's you know when you're on
twitter and you're scrolling that thing
it's like any social media that you're
on actually except for locals
you know you're basically just going
through things and you're welcoming them
into your world and if you're following
people that you don't agree with or like
or whatever you're just you're just
bringing that in all the time so i do
follow people that i disagree with but i
did have to there were like a bunch of
people that were like that i admired or
that i like their work you know bette
midler is a funny one like it's not that
i you know like she was a funny actress
and comedienne and then she called me
racist on twitter and i had to unfollow
her and then i can't watch first wives
club anymore which i thought was a great
movie because every time i see it it
makes me think that's the woman who
called me racist on twitter the episode
of seinfeld where she's playing on the
softball team and kramer crashes into
her and sends her to the hospital you've
seen it conor i can't watch it anymore
cause it's like she called me a racist
or mark hamill who's become a complete
maniac and luke skywalker is my hero
these people have that's why actually
one show that i'm watching right now we
just finished it last night the first
season which is actually a good show
believe it or not
the gilded age on hbo it's by the guy
who did uh julian fellowes who did
downton abbey
and it's about sort of 1880s like the
explosion of wealth in new york city and
it's really fascinating edison lights
the light bulbs for the first time in
new york city and it's it's just
wonderful and i've really come to love
period pieces because i think they give
you a little glean into another life and
and let you look at the world through
through older eyes it's really wonderful
if any of you are watching it i'd love
to talk about it um
but it's nice to see some things that
are
older and different and remind you
of uh some of the good stuff that we've
got now that people had had not quite as
good before that
ain't that the truth uh kate says are
things like the parental rights bill
constitutional carry in 25 states and
elon's twitter purchase a sign the tide
is turning yes i do think so it's why
i've been talking about these things
the
the tide is
turning and the side that's winning is
not always the side that will be winning
but you got to see it you got to see it
and model it that's what i said before
about the desantis thing it's like
that needs to now be modeled into other
states so the fact that yunkan won
the fact that desantis is crushing it so
hard here the fact that parents are up
at schools fighting against crt the fact
that people are canceling disney
accounts as they're trying to
indoctrinate children these are all good
signs the fact that elon musk put his
money where his mouth is and said i will
get involved in twitter let's see i mean
the jury's still out we'll have to see
what happens but these are good signs so
so know that the good signs are out
there and how about this know that steve
jobs who i started this video with he
believed that if you poke the world you
might be able to do something maybe he's
right
diane says are you going to record any
of your book tour events would love to
watch yeah we're trying to figure that
out my guys are going to come to some of
the stops we'll do some behind the
scenes stuff we'll do some handheld
camera stuff maybe we'll have some you
know official video at the events but
basically for all the events we're gonna
have somebody open up for me for five or
ten minutes do a little bit about life
get everybody enjoying themselves get
settled in their seats i'll give about a
45-minute talk and then the guests will
then moderate a q a uh where it'll be
some of the audience questions their own
questions they'll ask me some stuff
we'll play with the crowd i'm going to
give away shirts and it's just going to
be fun i'm looking forward to it
daverubin.com
uh tj says do you worry that podcasts
like yours daily wire candice
conservative voices on twitter etc are
just a bunch of us talking to each other
and the message isn't really reaching a
larger larger audience outside of those
that are super passionate about these
issues sometimes i feel like no one else
outside knows what we stand for thoughts
so this is a great question it's
something i think about a lot
because i don't want to a just be doing
my greatest hits to this to the same
people that have heard it before and b
i i don't think that politics is
everything so if i was only talking
about the same stuff
it wouldn't be worth my time and it
wouldn't be worth your time right so in
terms of the echo chamber effect you
know it's interesting because
there's a pretty wide variety if you
were to take say let's just take three
people for example oh let's let's take
four people so if you were to take me
ben shapiro glenn beck and dennis prager
you have four pretty different people in
terms of lifestyle where we live etc etc
um we all work for for different
networks we're all kind of doing
different things we've got a nice age
break if you even if you just took the
age break down there dennis is in his
early 70s glenn i think is in his late
50s um mid-40s ben is in his mid-30s
there's a nice age breakdown we have
some differences of political opinion
and we're all basically trying to fight
for america and for an america that we
all want to live in and that gives space
for those that are different than us to
live in as well um so
i think that to the best of our ability
we have to just kind of keep doing what
we're doing and keep being open and
welcoming it's why i do the show the way
i do it hopefully making you guys laugh
i mean one of the best things that i
heard this week people kept messaging me
saying dave the shows have been funnier
and funnier and it's like that's the way
you get people in um you know just
yesterday we had a company come here to
our house to do some landscape design
outside we've got some old dead trees
we're trying to refresh the place and uh
worked with this great guy for about a
half hour total pro i just totally
enjoyed talking to him and i was like
this guy's competent he gets what we
want he's showing us samples of things
and it was very obvious to me i was
going to hire the guy and at the end
when he's saying goodbye goes by the way
dave i'm a big fan of yours you know
you've really helped me politically blah
blah blah my daughter tells me the story
about his daughter a similar situation
and his wife is really red pilled in the
whole thing and it's like
how did this guy get red pill maybe
partly through what we do here maybe
there's somebody that watches the old
prageru why i left the left video who
still thinks they're a lefty but that
popped up somehow they start thinking
about some things next thing you know
they watch a dave rubin video and then
what happens they somehow that then
connects them to jordan peterson next
thing you know they're standing up
straight with their shoulders back then
they're getting their life in order then
they start thinking about politics a
little bit differently and hot damn next
thing you know you're watching a ben
shapiro video and ben shapiro is
explaining things about the deficit now
you have a little more understanding
about that and then you turn on glenn
beck and you see glenn beck talking
about what's going on with the great
reset and all that so i think we can all
hit things from different points but
your overall
point is a good one we don't want to go
just into that echo chamber we want to
make sure we're making a dent but to the
question that i believe was before that
this stuff's leaking out this stuff's
actually leaking out it is affecting the
real world we are waking up people we're
seeing results in elections
and uh
as steve jobs said
poke it see what happens see what
happens people
in closing
five days from now my new book don't
burn this country comes out have you
heard that i have a website it's called
daverubin.com and if you go to
davereuben.combook you can get that very
book you can pre-order it and it'll be
at your doorstep on april 12th let's get
it on that ridiculous fraudulent new
york times bestseller list and if you'd
like to join me on tour daveruben.com
events and yes the dc show is back on
same link don't return your tickets etc
etc if you'd like to play along at home
reubenreport.locals.com